in New Zealand one lane bridges are a
common enough thing that tourists are
warned about them the rules are simple
approach with care go slowly and if
there's someone coming the other way
then sometimes there are signs that'll
tell you who has priority there is an
exception to that rule in just a couple
of places though which is that
regardless of what those signs say
always let the train go first the main
railway started operating in the 1990s
and we ran a tourist train business we
cared about eighty to ninety thousand
persons of the year the route is a
hundred and fifty four kilometers
returned from Dunedin and follows a
River Gorge up through the tyree River
up on to the stressed re plane the
scenery is particular how they built it
where they started in 1879 it was
completed in 1891 all by hand it is a
challenging route it's a really up and
down just to be clear this isn't a tram
or a trolley bus or light rail this is
an actual train running on the street
here because that was a better option
than trying to build a second bridge on
a very quiet Road technically I guess
this is just a very strangely shaped
level crossing and there are a few other
bridges like this around the world but
almost all of them have lights and
sirens and barriers to keep cars
separated when there's a train
approaching here you just take care and
listen out for the train horn when the
road prints further up the river failed
they made the rail bridge a road bridge
you used to be a lot more in the country
it was a cheap option why build two
bridges when you can build one there are
mainly built in less populated areas
because trains and cars don't usually
combine very well so he wouldn't build
them in the cities though cars just have
to follow the road rules these stop
signs at either end of the bridge and
you don't do light speed going up onto a
road rail bridge you're doing 10
kilometers an hour blowing the whistle
on all this living Hendon Road rail
bridge is really the only to give access
to two sheep stations so there's not
that much traffic on it really you come
across a car anyway the trains going at
a speed that it can stop pretty easily
and usually the cars after their car
we've never had a problem on a road
which level crossings of whiz
you